the remix to your single feel good is a
vibe
okay thank you
and the song is about just embracing
yourself you know inner confidence self
love all of that
when did you learn to put yourself first
uh i'm still learning it's a work in
progress
i come from a place of people pleasing
and i don't want to disappoint people
and that was sort of a lot in my family
and i was the entertaining diplomat so i
want to make sure everybody's okay
and then you realize oh while you're
managing other people's feelings you're
not managing and making sure you're okay
and so that's of course where the song
was born from is that like
you really got to be in the business of
taking care of yourself because you
can't you won't be good to anyone else
if you're not
but it seems chrissy has found that
balance especially when it comes to her
blossoming relationship with boyfriend
bradley collins
i love that the two of you guys you met
on a dating app like i don't think
people realize that celebrities need to
use
apps too we're we're humans
yeah and also we have crazy schedules
that don't always
provide time or opportunity to meet
people because you don't necessarily
want to date someone you're working with
i try to be slick and i'm like oh if
people actually care about getting to
know me
they'll ask questions as opposed to just
like oh she happens to be on a tv show
and he's like i really thought it was
sort of a catfish for
you know for the better part of our
first conversation i think for a minute
he was like
is she real and especially since i
didn't have too much i haven't
had anything really on the bio but just
but pictures that were like personal
pictures
yeah you know that you couldn't find on
instagram so
ladies people gentlemen put some of them
in your bio
okay and although chrissy and bradley
are going strong
things may be getting a little rocky
over on this is us
stuff's getting good things are getting
good
we weren't sure if kate and toby were
going to be taking their little babe
home
me you and two under two exactly
face a cake so we're gonna see how kate
and toby
um are gonna finagle this new this
really beautiful new addition to their
family and
is it going to affect their relationship